wait a little bit there there's no PA
right so like I feel like actually you
can you hear me at the back sort of okay
I know if I start mumbling too much so
hey this is the http/2 workshop just to
make sure everyone's in the right place
okay so you are
I'm Sebastian Decker's I'm sort of just
open source guy for the last year hb2
sort of been my project we can hack it
hack project thing and then sort of it's
been going completely dominating my life
for the last year half I've been working
on this for a long time now and I'd like
to share some of what I've learnt along
the way and built along the way so I'm
going to start with like a little
introduction on HTTP to but before we do
that like who here's actually using HP
to or knows sort of a little bit about
it already
okay that's like if there's okay
fantastic who is shy of raising their
hands okay everyone all right
so excellent so like I am just gonna
touch like sort of lightly on HTTP -
because the protocol itself is actually
really similar to HTTP one which I mean
we've all okay we're all web developers
here like I don't to make too many
assumptions so like if you're like
coming in here from a Rath Haskell
functional programming background and
you've never seen the web then let me
know but I'll assume like certain things
about like your knowledge of HTTP that
you've understand what a request and a
response are you've ever built a web app
that serves a response to out requests
right but what's different in HTTP 2 is
some of these basic things that I'll
just go through now so the first concept
that is really interesting is you have
streams instead of just sockets so HTTP
1 everything goes over one socket right
that means a TCP level socket so to have
this starter provided and your HTTP goes
on top of that with every single request
you need to have a socket and then you
can send one request wait for a response
send another request
wait for another response introduces
certain things like head-of-line
blocking which is essentially when you
have a request that's going out and it's
like a really huge response that you're
waiting for you any other requests in
the meantime wait for you know the the
the original response to finish before
they can go out over that same socket
hp1 you address that with things like
opening you know six or eight sockets
all right are you joining for HTTP -
alright just set yourselves down
somewhere we've already started but you
know just the beginning
okay yeah yeah yeah yeah fine
oh that's my back
okay so for the newcomers as well I'm
just explaining someone a very basic
theory it's a little dry it's a little
bit conceptual but we'll get into code
very quickly and then you get more of a
an intuitive feeling once you start
coding and actually using these concepts
so I'm just talking about streams
basically consider a HTTP 1 has a socket
where you have to like wait for a
response and a request to finish before
you do the next one with streams the
idea is that you have one socket and
over that you have over over that socket
instead of sending out your request
right away you can chunk it up into
little little packets called frames and
these frames can have a this identifier
the stream identifier is ID that
basically let's pretend the various
stream IDs like various headers and
various data fragments on the same
electricity socket so you can have
multiple requests going out at the same
time and then some of the responses
start trickling back data frames and
sort of by doing this all over one
socket you gain some some benefit in
this head of line blocking you no longer
have to like wait for the response to
finish but that was sort of that is the
design of HTTP 2 in practice it turns
out that you bet you basically just
pushed a head of line mocking down in
our level so most tutorials that you'll
read out there are going to be like oh
my god we solved HP two solves head of
line blocking it doesn't actually in
practice because you just sort of push
it down one level which is why in the
last few years people have been working
on this new spec called quick quick is
basically dropping TCP altogether and
just putting everything directly over
UDP and implementing sort of the
similarities of like what TCP offers
this whole there were retransmission and
control flow implementing that in its
own spec on top of like within UDP and
we'll talk a bit more about that later
and what that brings but the focus will
be on HTTP two and you can you can sort
of a assume that quick sort of like a
supplemental to to http - it's not
fundamentally changing the concepts of
what we're talking about here so we've
just covered a little bit of streams
frames like I said you kind of chop up
your data into frames right so I'm not
going through like too much details
right now we'll see more later and we
actually start using these things
it also offers header compression it's
called H pack there's actually a couple
of proposals right now to to change H
back to newer newer compression schemes
they may or may not be some security
vulnerabilities there's also some some
things that it doesn't offer like right
now it like for instance if you compress
if you have streams that all go to the
same domain name the same Authority or
host or origin whatever you call it but
the terminology sort of blurs but over
the different versions of HTTP but if
you if you send headers to like
example.com and then you would send it
to example at net those headers are
compressed with a separate dictionary so
you don't you don't have the full
efficiency so this is something people
want to fix now by mmm Cousy yeah I mean
it it's just a little line it says
really matter by the way you can just
access this yourself if you want to like
skip ahead if you get bored or anything
I'm not gonna hold you back can you see
this URL
no damn it
something like that so feel free to skip
her I'm just I don't wanna hold you back
okay so like I was saying each pack
people trying to fix that as well so
just because I'm I mention these things
now doesn't mean that they'll be the
same in like a couple of years little
parts of the protocol are actually
already evolving and we'll even try
using some of the newer extensions that
have been adopted for http/2 and even
some of the experimental ones which is
kind of cool okay you got it
get it from your neighbor so we also
have priorities and dependencies this is
a new concept in ht1 there's no such
thing but now you've got a concept of
streams that can be dependent on another
stream because they're all on the same
socket the server could now determine
which ones should be prioritized so so
if you have let's say you're you're an
image right that's maybe not not as high
up on the page you can give it a lower
priority and the server can interpret
that as a suggestion from the client or
as a hint to say okay I'm gonna send you
everything else with a high priority I'm
gonna allocate more bandwidth on this
socket to them you know the higher
priority resources I will say that in
practice like this is this is a sort of
concept inspect in practice doesn't
really work okay so different servers
implement is differently most sort of
really just ignore it
browsers also have very differing
opinions about how to create this
dependency tree some of which are really
just a queue so you have a tree where
like you have one branch and in another
branch and another branch it doesn't
really help okay so it this is something
that people are playing with but it's
really unless you're doing the research
specifically on that area and you try
and optimize something it's not really
gonna be a very huge impact but it's a
lot of complexity if you're implementing
it so yeah great choice spec designers
so yeah we've got another thing clients
and servers can negotiate settings when
a client connects it has a certain
amount of settings that it sends in is
like the first one of the first teams to
the server and the server will respond
back with its own settings so settings
can be things like
saying like okay how many how many
streams kind of have open and maximum at
any given time now the default in the
spec recommends to never go below a
hundred chrome actually says like a
thousand streams you know so this is
like a thousand requests in responses
could be open at the same at the same
time on on a single socket like that's
pretty liberal like that's pretty you
know generous other things are like
receive windows and things like that so
like we don't have do we have enough
chairs okay okay okay sorry about that
right now just like space to sit in the
front if you want to get closer can you
hear me okay there okay so yeah a little
bit of setting negotiation we'll try to
use some of those for instance one of
the one of the key ones is the clients
can also enable or disable server push
which is the other thing that I wanted
to mention is and that was my personal
and the thing that got me into HP too a
couple of years ago
speedy back then was server push because
I really liked the idea that the server
can just eliminate any wasted round
trips by saying to the client here's
some file that I'll also send you in
response to your request so let's say a
browser visits a website requests you
know example.com slash you know just
like the index.html the server would
normally serve that takes some time to
get to the client to client processes
parses this thing and then goes and says
okay now I need my you know app das and
I need my styles that my design dot CSS
and whatever so there's a lot of that
round-trip time that is typically wasted
it's called think time in some context
and with push you could actually
eliminate that when we push if the
server knew what the client would need
to go along with that page it could push
along those assets right away so that's
a really cool idea I thought and so I
this is what I've been working towards
and we'll use this later and I'll talk
about some of the actually there's some
of the problems with that what wasn't
maybe foreseen and how we can address
those then so we'll go pretty deep on
that and then lastly here's a the
coalescing connection kind of
idea which which fits into the whole
streams so it's streams you basically
have like like let's say all the
JavaScript files all the image files all
the CSS files from your website can go
onto the same TCP socket at the same
time but now let's say that you're on a
CDN a CDN is like a service that like
like CloudFlare you might have heard
over fastly or Akamai and many other
large companies offer CDN services like
so what happens is that a lot of people
put their website on to those services
to host them from servers around the
world because when you put servers
around the world you get those servers
get closer these edge servers get closer
to large population centers of the world
and that eliminates the latency and
which is always the having low latency
is the best solution to any performance
issue basically on on the web if you
have really low latency if you're like
in Singapore and requesting from the
data center in one North you never never
gonna notice that you're doing 100 round
trips because you can do it in like a
tenth of a second right cool
claim I wrote it
okay so so any anyway with them once you
once you're on the CDN for all these
various performance reasons there's this
concept of coercing connections where
you could say I'm going to establish
connection to my site my example or
domain but then I need to connect I need
to like mmm load something from API dot
example are calm because I have a single
page app that's talking to an API and
what's happening now is it you can put
the both of those domains onto a CDN
that serves a signal certificate with
like maybe like a TLS certificate to
secure the connection which lists both
of these domain names and then the mine
is able to connect to request from both
of those origins on the same connection
so you eliminate the entire the need to
set up another connection which is
actually a rather expensive process in
terms of latency because to set up a
socket takes like two round-trip to do
that in TLS it's like another two round
trips at least and before you can undo
your HTTP request right that's for four
round trips at least possibly more
because the size of the certificate
might you know include increase the
amount of bandwidth that exceeds it a
single round trip the idea is that you
can serve multiple domains on the same
on the same like TCP socket the same
connection right and if you combine all
these things together we can start
moving towards a very different way of
delivering web applications where you
have zero latency like or you have the
minimal theoretical amount of latency
between your client and your server you
you have zero the wasted think time
because you're constantly your service
constantly pushing data down that pipe
to fill the maximum copy of capability
this is very important in places where
there isn't an abundance of CDN
infrastructure available right now so
this allows you to serve like from
Singapore SI toos to customer in America
or in South Africa without having
necessarily like setting up servers or
and all these places so there's there's
a lot of concepts there and I'll talk
about like sort of how I've been
experimenting with those and actually
using them in practice and what tools we
can use to do this and we'll start with
some very will start with taking just a
closer look and these
these protocols the data that's actually
being sent so we got familiar Moorthy
with the sort of the primitives of the
protocol I will point out that my little
rant here is probably not the best
explanation and what is probably the
best explanation is this really rather
excellent faq written by I think Mark
nothingham
one of the authors of the I think is one
of the chairs of the IETF HTTP working
group so he's been he's been doing this
for decades he's really really good at
it and he's writes rather nicely so you
should actually go through this I I
think that out of all the tutorials that
I've ever seen about HTTP two none are
as good as the actual spec it's very
easy to read spec it takes like maybe an
hour and if you're intent on working
with this I highly recommend just sit
down and go through it take your time
and as you're working with it so just
like look at the spec as your source of
truth rather than looking at like blog
posts and tutorials and talks like this
these I'm just trying to facilitate what
and explain what I've learned but I'm
not like better than the spec okay so
look at these things and I found a
router really a sort of enlightening so
right there's the actual that said I was
the FAQ so this is under the HTTP the
HTTP working group the IETF is this
thing in the top right here it's okay
come on position static so the ITF thing
here that's a standards body that it's
really an open organization anyone can
participate in these discussions they
mostly take place on mailing lists these
are people from around the world but who
work for all kinds of companies that are
competitors of each other most of the
time browser vendors and like I said CD
ends and open source you know hackers
and they have various working groups for
different protocols so most of the
problems that I've mentioned so far like
TCP and UDP and and quick and TLS and
DNS and HTTP they're all standards set
up by working groups the WG is a working
group and that fall under the ITF
organization and they sort of have a lot
of process around it to make sure that
this facility
fairly openly and anyone can participate
in this in fact just last month I think
two months ago or last month they had
the 100 meeting in person
and happened in Singapore and I was
fortunate enough to attend it for my
first time and it was the best tech
conference I've ever been to because it
wasn't really like a tech conference
like this where you go to attend
workshops it was just people discussing
this spec like people actually like
would get up and propose something and
people like then debate these theses
constants it was very very very very
nice very enjoyable I and I was sort of
attending and I was able to contribute
as well even though I don't work for a
Google or a Mozilla or whoever that was
there I can just go as an independent
person and say okay I've worked on the
note
and with it but like everyone just
speaks for themselves nobody speaks for
their employer for instance so everyone
is on an equal equal footing and can
fairly contribute their feedback and
ideas so if you interested in that at
all
take a look at the mailing lists under
the HTTP working group so you'll find
all of that here at the HTTP WG org and
over here is the mailing lists this is
where all of the discussion happens so
personally I don't discuss a lot there
but I do lurk so that's a good way to
sort of people keep stay abreast of
what's coming up and you'll see things
that might not even exist for another
two or three years in browsers and such
but you must be aware of that you'll see
what's coming so this I think this is
very valuable for any web developer just
of keep you know keep up to date and
stay ahead of what's up to date around
right now so this is like I mean you
just use some really interesting
discussions happening and it's kind of
cool to see like the names coming back
and who is this who's working on it
you'll start seeing like who's which
browser may or may not be implemented in
which features and all that so anyway
take a look at those so then first thing
we can do is a couple of tools to look
at HTTP to traffic I was gonna suggest
that you first open up like chrome like
your inspector if chrome installed most
of you hopes okay so alright so let's go
to a web site let's see Jess conf oh
hang on
who here knows that on Sunday there's a
meet-up called Co PJs yeah all right so
she as an aside if you're around on
Sunday I don't know for the visitors who
might be a little difficult but if
you're around at all on Sunday morning
there's a meet-up called Co PJs where
people just gather it's not really
hundreds in JavaScript but they're
mostly like developers there but you
don't need to actually talk about coding
or anything like that it's just a nice
way to socialize and you know meet some
people over a cup of local Singapore
coffee so check it out anyway point is
we have this website open we have
another inspector
go to network tab reload all right here
we go so this is happening over protocol
h2 okay so that's our that's our basic
our first clue of that this is not like
a standard old HTTP 1 website now the
next thing you do you go to Chrome slash
net internals that's a little lower
level debugging in the browser and if
you go to HTTP 2 on the left hand side
they're just too small for the people
the back can you sort of see it is it
too small or okay okay I mean I could
better so I'm not sure if you can see
the URL so let me just magnify that
separate what's that short key on Mac to
like you know as in like to to sort of
zoom the screen what is it called I
always forget that yeah that's that
zooms the content but not the browser
bar no I think it's like with a pinch
gesture and then some cookies or
whatever you'll be useful yeah I could
do the pasting but I'd have to like
every single time
you can just zoom parts of it Oh enable
track how's that work option command
no no I'm can combined I know whose it
was in Arabic
okay okay so anyway now we've got like a
little live overview of what's going on
here in the internals of the browser and
we can see our session here our live
sessions so echo PJs on port 443 which
is standard for TLS for like a HTTP URL
it's got this session here ID 385 and
probably we have to like reload this
page then we see it captured something
so come on stop stop capture okay okay
it's quite annoying
okay okay all right I'll do like that so
on your computer probly have to struggle
with the zooming thing and all that but
basically you can see like really level
information on what actually happened
how the browser requested it we start
seeing some some general events so you
see here like it well that was like
because we reloaded it first closed it
and probably received some settings
there clearing this thing out where do
we open it again
one second
okay and these are these tools are a
little bit finicky so bear with me
please
why is it off
okay
in life then was our the best oh here we
go okay so we've got we've got like a
little idea of what's going on here so
our session this is the request the way
it goes out because it's all binary it's
basically this is a decoded view of that
binary like if you were looking at the
actual binary I'm just like rendering it
as ASCII you will just get a bunch of
garbage because everything's compressed
like I said so it's compression kind of
like makes it very efficient but also
totally not human readable anymore right
so this is decoded this is uncompressed
and in a representation so this is just
a debugger panel this is not literally
the bytes that are going out relates to
b1 the bytes I go out are pretty much
literally like this just that they get
wrapped inside TLS here the a lot of
this looks very familiar but you can
already see him differences you have
these pseudo headers in in an HTP one it
would look different I know if you're
familiar but in HP one that would look
the first line of the request is
basically just get and then the protocol
name and version and then the path right
and if you put HTTP two because there's
no like text-based
line by line protocol these getting
coded as headers so that they can also
be compressed and so they're prefixed
with this column so that they never
clash so if you see any meters that do
not start with colon and these are those
sort of regular headers like the ones I
start with colon are defined by the RFC
and are sort of reserved pseudo headers
and these get compressed really
efficiently so they don't take as much
bandwidth this actually what you see on
the screen also if you have repetitive
once they completely sort of encoded to
their entropy entropy values so you see
a lot of these session like this this
singing session has a lot of streams
going over it we can start seeing things
like the parent stream ID for this one
is zero that's the root is zero the then
the take sort of incrementally go up the
in terms of the stream ID so there's
there's this difference between even and
odd numbers of stream IDs depending on
whether it's like initially by the
client or from or by the server like
which direction is going so you can kind
of tell they can go up to like 31 bits
so it's like a billion streams either
direction so you should never be
exhausting that actually
now basically this is one way of looking
at the the debugging thing what I wanted
to actually do is install some of these
tools
who's got curl on their system probably
everyone who has used curl before okay
cool cool so just try to run like for
those who have not and for those who
have not yet seen HTTP to being
inspected with curl just run curl oh
okay just run curl - verbose and then
the the URL HTTP copy gesture org
so you'll see all this content right but
all the way the top you see the
interesting part girl actually gives you
kind of an insight into how it sets up
the connection with TLS and
what's being sent with the headers so
that the at the top you see things like
this LPN or Alpine that's like how it's
negotiating whether this server is
actually HTTP 1.1 or HTTP 2 that's part
of TLS so you see things like the exact
handshake and a certificate exchange so
these are a lot of round trips that are
going on so in future versions of the
protocol this is one of the things that
we're trying to eliminate these kind of
round trips you'll see things like which
kind of what kind of certificate is it
what else is it using to sign and digest
and everything you see some details of
the actual certificate so in this case
for instance the CN the sense of a
common name is co PJ and copy jester org
so this certificate is only has copies s
on it so when we were talking about
coalescing connections you need to have
like multiple domains on the same
certificate the certificate would not be
able to do that so it's also signed by
let's encrypt which is like a very
common way now most of most certificates
are now signed by let's encrypt it's a
free service that is available on most
hosting companies free of charge and
integrate this yourself then ok then we
see the regular headers so this is
fairly standard HTTP stuff where you see
the method so the reason it doesn't show
this as actually like this is not
actually what was sent out this is a
little bit of a lie by coral so the
actual thing that gets sent out as those
compressed headers which have a pseudo
header that coulomb method cool on path
and this is just curls representation
because curl is kind of like a tool
that's been around for ages
and I'm guessing inter for the user
interface this was a smaller way to make
it familiar to everyone else so but this
is not 100% accurate but it gives you a
good idea of what's going on okay then
another tool that wanted to share which
is specifically built for HTTP 2 is NG
HTTP so this one you probably have to do
or hanji http/2 org
so if you go to this website here engine
http/2 org this is an open source
library that implements HTTP - it's
written in C it's the it's the
underlying library for tools like curl
it's also what's used in like a safari
browser the Apache web server uses it
and node.js also uses this and it comes
with its own command-line various tools
are included one is a client that we can
now use the the command when you install
this on your system you should actually
try this now this is we're going to be
using this or you oh you can even do
your you can do it okay so Indian we'll
walk you through how to get this working
on your computer view this one yeah yeah
that's cool
it's a doctor thing who's got docker on
your system okay cool nice
you don't have no please consult
[ __ ]
it didn't even recognize that yes we let
me tie into that oh it's fine I just do
it in this
or do you think this is
nope
okay I think your computer needs this to
work it needs to be kind of like it
might be easier to install it with
hungry someone has that yeah yeah okay
so would you put your teamwork is that
I'm yeah sure
well yeah it's not imaginary so we
things like a great suggestion there we
can use homebrew to install this on our
own machines that's actually what I do
as well
the demo was going to be a little bit
more of a testing thing if we can get
that okay that's fine so if you have a
Mac and if you are able to install it by
a brew just do that this the docker was
mainly for those who don't have UNIX or
Mac with I'm not having titled on
Windows yet so the docker container is
mainly for that but if you are able to
install any HTTP to this all
instructions on the website I didn't
know it does not prove but if it's there
just follow the government actually so
one thing we could do is show to show
the demo for the load testing okay I
would like to
for my collection
everybody all right I'm not sure I can
get everybody in here so you have to be
representative with the corn exit thank
you so much or do we do another one oh
[Laughter]
yeah sorry
so next level Instagram so yeah set up
Angie http/2 is here already and it so
ndh still producer see liability which
implements a lot of the lower level
connection stuff
yep okay anyone able to install it so
far
who's installed it already so forth
so in case you are not able to install
it yourself just I have a docker
container with everything set up so it
can just go to the site II oh sorry
that's the local of stretchy this is
again yeah should be able to access this
this has the stuff setup so that if you
are unable to install or finding some
problems installing this should help you
get started
this is quite big though it's a nearly
18 MB so you know just see fury
you have problems installing just let me
know something else additional that you
install I do something except but this
should get yeah that's actually
predicting okay okay it's good enough
oh yeah okay good point so if you want
to access this URL make sure you are on
the J's conf Wi-Fi network there are two
networks yeah password is beware of the
cat sitting beware of the cats is a
password
10:10 one what
is anyone in stable to access this URL
No
you can access it which Wi-Fi network I
own which one are you
unless someone else's will be king that
way filter
you have oh yeah yeah VPN or something
or firewall nothing okay then uh
automatically so dish
do you have brute yeah yeah yeah
yeah you should
oh that's it's good laughs this gitlab
gita levy it should be power attacking
yes I don't know the exact URL hopefully
there's no more Sebastian's really no no
I know save it access it today money Wow
then let's do definitions of you know
something might be somewhere something
is downloading what is this oh no it's
I think it's just too slow you probably
need to it's hundred kbps not that but
yeah it was the main thing for you to
get installed anyone else has problem
installing the ng HTTP do library can
follow the installation instructions if
the binaries taking too long to download
so this is basically a C++ liability
which is provides a lot of the low level
abstractions for managing the actual
frames that get sent over the HTTP to
connection so different servers build on
top of this like for example node.js
chorus uses this library to manage some
of the different api's that we're
building for the code
so yeah this also comes with a tool
called hedge to load which we'll be
using to say load test HTTP one and HTTP
two connections that's what has set up
in the docker image but I think it might
take too long to demo
so one of the things that I'll be
showing this how how that summer there
is some different ways in which has
still be wonder has TB two are different
so one of the things in is where http/2
everything goes on the same connection
and different requests happen on
different streams as ourself just
mentioned so with HTTP one for each
request you need to open a different
socket and because of this there are
some security implications of that as
well so for example if you want to do
rate limiting or HTTP one right you
might said something like okay I don't
want more than say thousand connections
open at the same time on the server but
with HTTP to you
that's that paradigm changes because you
can with one connection you can have say
thousand streams at the same time which
can cause which can utilize a lot of
resources on your server so when you're
shifting to http - especially if you're
doing that on your own server not just
like using a CDN to manage your assets
and stuff you need to be fine you need
to fine-tune all these settings on your
server for example nginx has a lot of
different directives to manage number of
channel open sessions and stuff like
that so the thing I wanted to show here
is like how with minimum amount of
resources and attacker can generate a
lot of traffic with the same with with
HTTP - versus HTTP 1 so with HTTP - it's
pretty cheap to start up sort of start
make a request you just start a new
stream and make a request with that
stream with HTTP 1 it's different so
what I'm doing here is basically I'm
just starting a docker container with
I'm just limiting the amount of memory
and CPU which is able to use so yeah so
if you look at it I have done the same
thing I've just installed an D ng HTTP -
it also comes with a library called h2
load can look at the different
parameters yeah
so you can use different parameters to
fear load test your application the cool
thing about this is it allows you to
send requests both via HTTP 1 and htb -
so using this you can test which Tim
works better not works better with scorn
can send more this requests at the same
time so yeah one of the things you can
play around with number of requests that
you total number of requests that you
want to send and this is censored in
batches so you can say that ok send 100
requests at the same time I want you to
send a total of 10,000 requests and
number of threads you want to use I'm
just going going to use 1 because I just
have one core I have limited a docker
access to just one core number of
concurrent streams this only useful in
HTTP 2 can also force TP 1 so let me
just
good
so um so I'm just trying to send a lot
of traffic to a server make sure that
you can I've set up a sample server here
don't probably don't bring down the
copied a setup side but this is a desk I
don't care if it goes down so it's just
experiment at the executor comes the
thing is this server is also running on
a docker image it's very little
resources so there's a high chance that
it can go down of of course I am not
redirecting to HTTPS but okay
so so this is what I'm saying I'm saying
like send 10,000 requests 100,000
degrees I'll probably reduce that don't
want to say yeah let me see what this
does
okay so yeah it's able to send that
quite quickly so you think the chose
HTTP 2 because you by default it uses
HTTP 2 you can see the throughput here
and you can also play around with the
number of connections so within one
connection it has multiple streams I'm
starting 6 connections to see if that
improves throughput it depends on your
system configuration and stuff like that
with HTTP 1 the throughput is much more
lower so you can force HTTP 1 by sending
this flag called h1 so here if you try
to start a lot of connections at the
same time the docker images test crashes
like it I mean the it's not able to send
as many parallel requests as HTTP 2 and
you can play around with that so you can
see if you start setting seed that is
the number of open connections to say 15
or 20 they don't be able to handle it so
and you can see that it's much more
slower you can measure the throughput
you know just play around with this tool
it's good for measuring seeing what how
HTTP 1 and 2 are different for at a
fundamental level while using streams is
different from setting up a whole new
connection to it's more memory efficient
and stuff like that so you can just play
around with this
this has anyone has problem setting up
in DHT without trying out h2 load just
let me know
as you can see the requests start
failing aside
parallel connections which is very bad
with HTTP one so you can see that most
requests just fail because it's not able
to open that many parallel connections
but HTTP do this much more easier to do
so the URLs gitlab not github so if you
want access the readme this is the your
it was
get him access it right yeah
now we're able to access it that one
yeah yeah this down so have you
installed yeah so just think best so
there now there will be a tool called
its to load I think yeah so now you just
give it a URL and insta and you need to
can set the number of total request to
send how many requests to send in
parallel and play that and just monitor
your CP usage and last yearI of
basically there was a just purpose from
his company over James now who's a
really amazing node hacker were coming
primarily and Matteo was supporting him
in that and I contribute a little bit on
some compatibility or push support
testing and stuff like that but um to
minister to of h2 URL I don't know if
you call it hurl or what but jazz came I
guess but if you npm install' h2 URL it
gives you another option another tool
they could use to do similar things to
curl or chase different tune
so it's another option just npm install
this locally in your package or do a
global installed then you guys everyone
here missense and learn so something
like some something minor but not yet
seen is you can also ng xh2 URL and
that's basically like npm at the tool
comes with NPM so if you have note
installed on your system you need no 9.4
for this stuff by the way do stuff stay
with the latest one that's changing like
every week
so if you do npx it's an NPM because 2
NP x h2 URL and run the entire command
what happens is that NP X is like a
little helper and helper tool that NPM
installs it in like a temporary location
runs the command and when it finishes
running it removes it immediately again
so it's kind of like the benefit of
doing a global install without actually
polluting you know your your command
line things basically so try try NP x h2
URL - - super bowls and some URL put it
out it's a nice it's uh just a little
experimental thing
each of these can give you a slightly
different perspective like I was saying
or they're also like curl actually kind
of like home it's a few things about the
protocol but then it tells you a lot
more about TLS handshake so depending on
what you're debugging each of these cut
it might give you a different insight
and might help you solve the problems
okay I know for a fact that like the
browser tool sometimes are fictitious I
have to put it mildly like when you're
doing things like server push and then
you're trying to figure out why are
there more is hitting your server when
the browser tells you that it isn't you
know it can you can lead to interesting
things by look at the internals and
seeing oh for some reason opens up two
streams because some blog in a browser
leads to you know the favicon icon being
somehow on a separate bed because that's
being rented by a different part of the
user interface and it opens from UTC
something like that all these kind of
weird stuff happens and that's why it's
useful to have like the full suite of
debugging tools okay
all right so everyone's got like a
little bit of thing working out on
somebody
everyone's made a request and then
looked at htv-2 stuff who still like
need a little hand to go around
some of us vote
oh let me check this is basically it's
arson of note are you in
I think it's not understanding the async
function
yeah oh yeah
this tends to 9.4 yeah yeah this
definitely won't orchids by them make
sure they are at least on not eight or
nine yeah no yeah no yeah someone here
had a docker issue yeah what do I get
there
oh are you terminal with the Linux term
do you have that or you have a git bash
or something yeah just try it on -
that's what I mean because I think it's
failing because he didn't expect Yankee
passion
oh but it's darker and stuff installed
on parish just I'm using all dr.
everyday in the in this Oh Windows okay
oh I'm not sure that so no-legged he's
running a bash script in the
installation process being searched and
oh but this is bash as Oh
in Virtual Box we have Linux running or
something yes
no it's not in Russia box but I can run
everything okay
don't say
I haven't tried it in Windows sorry
this used to run
nothing okay
all right everybody got something
working so guys your hand raised up if
you don't have anything good passing it
okay I'm gonna go on to the next part
where we get more to the side of it
because I think of APA except a second
phone the push yeah so so the main thing
is like HTTP 2 is experimental in
node.js when you when you start using it
it'll throw a warning that's fine that's
supposed to be the case the reason it's
there
the reason is considered experimental is
because the API does still change a
little bit here and there and normally
if you change any API in node core even
even if it's the smallest thing like
like you change a typo in an error
message right that has to go through
really lengthy deprecation cycle that
could take years and years because of
LTS the long term stability a long term
support versions of note that could take
years to actually fully go out and just
waiting that long with HTTP 2 is just
not acceptable right now we we didn't
want to wait like years to actually ship
it in the state in the current version
of node and we also didn't want to have
to leave bugs trailing and trailing for
years potentially leaving people
vulnerable to security issues so that's
why HP 2 is just considered experimental
so if you're using it expect that some
of these api's might change so some of
the frameworks that you're using the
authors of those frameworks have to like
really pay attention to this and
constantly update so if you have a
dependency on like a web service or some
some some middleware that uses HTTP 2
you know you might want to be updating
that all the time whenever it is a new
version of node test it out before you
ship it in production so the current
latest release is 9 point 4.0 as of
yesterday that's what I'll be using so
the basic API the way that you use it is
really familiar
we've got require HTTP for HTTP 1.1 then
if you want to make that secure you use
TLS by requiring HTTPS that is almost an
exact same API if anyone's read any
documentation on HTTPS basically you get
a function called create server and with
ACPs you get a function called create
secure server right now if you do
require HTTP to
http/2 itself doesn't mandate TLS so you
can use it with or without it's a new
protocol but you can use with or without
TLS so you get both the create server as
well as creates or secure server
functions so with HTTP 2 you can skip
this difference here and just you can
choose yourself whether you want TLS or
not now you probably want TLS and I'll
I'll probably go into that in a little
second here but for now let's let's try
to build a server using just a
documentation so I want to do a little
exercise which is to create an HTTP 2
server and there's like a little cheat
right there so the very student level
and I'm sure it's like every single
person here has already seen the code
but try to create this without looking
at the actual exercise now look at the
documentation because the idea is that
you familiarize yourself with the
relation as your your reference so you
don't have to memorize api's and other
pointless trivia fact that changes all
the time just always refer to the node
documentation at no DSL org slash API
slash HTTP 2.8 EML and this is nice to
be written it's more or less if you see
typos you might want to contribute a bug
fix this is more or less up to date
there's a couple of errors in there and
I'll point out later that you might need
to go to the list latest latest like on
the repository itself because there's
some of the api's have changed like a
few weeks ago and and for some reason
the documentation was not rebuilt yet
now if you go here
you'll start see there's a core API and
there's a compatibility API so the
reason for this is that there well ok
essentially you have these layers of the
note the no tshp to operation one is the
ng h to be to library that we were
talking about so that library is the
lowest level of HTTP to in foundation
node that's written in C it's just
included in the source code in in the
noches repository it's just included as
a dependency untouched right there's the
exact code from the ng HTTP view
repository is included into the node.js
repository so it's completely standard
now the C++
part of note j/s itself is what binds to
the C code of this library and so
there's a lot of C++ code that was
written that exposes the API that ng
HTTP view offers exposes it in in node
c++ land so no most of the node
internals are written in c++ they baby
this is library called libuv which is
sort of an event loop library that does
all of the input output of a networking
all the file access all the operating
system hooks that's all c++ and it's
there the reason for that is because a
is high performance and B it's cross
platform so libel UV kind of exposes
file access and networking to like on
mac on windows on linux with a cop api
of exposes that event loop exposes the
v8 JavaScript engine bindings it's
posted all that in a nice high
performance and cross-platform manner
and so that's why we have to have c++ to
connect to any other library like ng
HTTP to for instance now because we are
using javascript this this c++ layer
exposes that its own api to a javascript
and like but in an internal javascript
library within within node and this is
sort of like a layer where it splits
into a core and a compatibility api and
we can we can use that in the
documentation so it's described as the
core API and a compatibility api the
compatibility api is trying to mimic
everything that the normal HTTP one api
X offers and the reason to that is
because you want to stay compatible to
provide an upgrade path for people who
are currently using the existing web
frameworks like happy or Express or
connect or all these things or any kind
of custom code or the note fetch all
these kind of things you want to make it
as easy as possible to migrate those
projects over so we we expose all of the
methods all of the properties as long as
they exist as concepts in HTTP to try to
map them to the same API but the core
API is going to offer you access to the
new concepts like push streams or the
streams and a session it's gonna offer
you access to like the h2 go to settings
it's gonna give you a lower level ax
a slightly higher performance because it
doesn't do as much like wrapping and
like extra lookups but performance plies
they're more or less the same you could
you can comfortably use a compatibility
labor API and I never face any issues
because of that so look at the core API
and just build a little nodejs server
it's really quite straightforward well I
mean okay I'm just gonna go ahead and
put this up here essentially like I said
you get a create server method from the
require HTTP to write you import it and
the the most fundamental event that you
can deal with any request as a stream
every request is essentially a new
stream a caption is a session you can
think of like a TCP connection is a
session and a stream is a request more
or less now when you end this session or
when this story when the stream opens
you receive this stream object which is
in documentation and you also get the
headers already decoded so the stream
actually you only receive this event
once it fully parsed and processed all
of the headers the headers could be
split across multiple fragments so it's
sort of the the the API kind of waits
for all those to come in and once once
it's completely done it'll give you the
full of decoded decompressed normalized
and everything sort of safe to work with
headers object and that's just a map no
prototype just a map of raw like key
value fully decoded so I've got a little
logic here to sort of hot show what this
does so you can you can look at the day
API and document run this yourself write
this yourself or you just copy-paste
this and just try to run this on your
system and then play around using the
tools that we set up earlier the
debugging clients that we have hit
against your own local server so
Oh Jess but now you can try to ddos this
one on your own under machine okay
what's happening here is normally you
would you do like something like send
head or right head or whatever I always
forget the API there's a new API who
called respond where you just give it
all these headers and remember the
status code in HTTP 2 is not like this
magical field in the first line it's
just another pseudo header so when
you're sending all your header so you
can now send your status code like your
200 your 404 your 500 whatever it is you
can just send it as this : status header
name with the value being this this
number so you just send your send these
send this response and then you that's
just going to send the header fragment
out to the to the client and then you
can send any kind of data as a stream so
you can you can pipe files to your
response in you can like do a create
file a crate read stream from a file or
take any kind of stream mail you have a
node and you can pipe it to this stream
and it'll automatically flush all the
data and do the buffering all really
nicely but it this is a simple way to
just send a string out there so if you
connect to your port 8080 with your ya
know so that's that's a key thing the
browser won't actually work right now
this is just a create server so this is
there's no TLS there's no HTTP or
anything like that that's why I'm
leaving port 8080 to me they the port 80
is support 80s for HTTP and port 443 as
a default port for TLS all right so HP
and HP ICF port 80 and 443 the reason
why I'm using 8080 is because any port
below 1024 on UNIX you have sudo access
and it just complicates things
needlessly and you might have already
has something running on there so I use
my values are usually this is personal
preferences like 8080 and 8,000 for 443
so I just changed this 82 or 443 in the
other demos so keep that in mind when
you're when you're requesting this that
you're using so if you hit this with
your browser your browser will just go
like oh I can't connect it at all
we'll do a demo we're like how did you
two have to do this
TLS thing after this so okay I wanna see
that I've actually achieved this step so
we have some HP two servers running
anybody have a alright
is this your local server hearing okay
yeah yeah looks good
and then there's data on your so my
first response header data here how many
oh hello there is you sort of printed in
line here
nice good luck good job you can try um
you can try doing things like piping a
file to it or something like you can
read the local file type it to that
response
you got it awesome it's quick so the :
think that's a pseudo header to do PS
you do so that's basically when an HTTP
to you don't have this like I need to be
one you have like get space HTTP slash
1.1 space and then slash the URL right
the path so that's the first line of the
request but in to you don't have like a
line of your request anywhere it's
binary so there's no concept of like the
first line and so to just to have those
concept they sort of map it to these
pseudo header stuff so each part of that
so the the method is like : method
header and then the status is the 200
it's like cool on status and then
there's a colon path for the slash blah
blah blah so then Apple that because
then it just fits into the 80 pack
header compression so this header frame
just contains header header header
header header and then this H pack
compresses the whole thing no matter
what it is right a header can have any
name so this is quote path it's all just
the same so it compresses it so that's
why it maps this concept a little bit
but yeah we still have to deal with like
now in HP - if you request HP do you
have these kind of pseudo headers and
you don't have the list in standard
that's why in the compatibility layer
you can actually treat it like the
normal hv1
api but in the core with the core API
are using now you have to deal with like
: status and : path
are you doing oh you're bending my code
now okay you got it yeah
all good here very working Bacchus you
prefer to type instead of food
oh it's a responder
okay how are you guys yeah
Oh see thank you for coming to go huh
okay you got it running and then use the
yeah in just not the x-axis the server
what a proxy yeah NGH yeah and then just
like it's based veal over hot and I
maybe want to do for both wait
nice hello world so you can see all the
frames here that gets you like the
headers frame coming out with the pseudo
headers and everything in there
what's good
I got coffee yeah yeah that's fine
[Music]
Oh how's it going oh that's something
wrong this is excellent ideas I've never
got no done you have you have you got a
note from your computer right okay and
then have you tried to exercise thank
you an apple any helpful okay you prefer
to film it's fine if you wanna read on
your own that's okay okay how's it going
yeah but it doesn't work with oh you're
trying to turn turn into HTML yeah
where's the port yeah so you doesn't
work there that's right so the browser
doesn't allow HTTP - without encryption
so we'll show I'll show like how to set
it up to the encryption locally you know
it's kind of tedious painful sometimes
locally you read your own yes look at my
tutorial I mean you can skip ahead I
guess another so there's a I mean I just
I have like some yeah some tools and
whatever you know just published
despondent I mean I've been using this
forever but I never had a public yeah
try it out
I don't know hmm
what is this
okay okay hang on here need property pfx
anything things the only different
exercise I think you copied from the
second one Ruby yeah this is already the
secure server so the first is the basic
server
that's funny this looks this looks okay
but can you make sure that this is safe
and then try to run the file well using
hmm
what is Inc I see what's happening okay
so you the version of node is very old
and so you did an NPM install of H 2 B 2
which is somehow like a module that's
really old and basically they look at
fixed by operating 2 node 9 point 4.0
the latest current released
I can I can curl it and I can you know
in the browser the browser doesn't allow
plain text and so you can only do a two
Bs only for a to be wonderful
they did not do that how can talk about
why okay cuz everyone's having that no I
think that's good everyone's getting to
that point excellent yeah yeah exactly
exactly
you know you can just see you
did everyone use ng HTTP to connect to
it I guess right most people seem to be
doing that because that's what we were
using before if anyone used curl they
might find that it's not possible to
just connect by default that's why I've
changed a command here sneakily - this -
- HTTP to - prior - knowledge this is
basically telling curl that don't worry
this is HTTP - because otherwise you
might be wondering like how does how
does a browser or any user agent know
what which protocol to use if you're
using HTTP - it's all binary it's like a
completely different handshake when do
you when the browser the client sends
its request it's completely different on
the wire than what an HTTP 1 client
would send and so you wouldn't be able
to connect to this you might have also
noticed that your browser struggles to
open this in a page like some people
have reported this now like if you open
it in a browser
it just doesn't load and it show you
some tea less hair or some whatever
protocol error thing now
so for curl you can you can tell it that
don't you have to use HTTP to 100%
double confirm HP - prior knowledge
right if you just do - - HTTP - it'll
try to do what's called an upgrade
mechanism which is a way that the HP -
protocol declares that to a to an HP one
client with a specific header with the
upgrade header that says I also support
HTTP - which tells the client to then
sort of switch to HTTP - mode and start
sending HTTP to traffic on that same
connection so that's a very slow you
know distant there's a there's a wasted
round-trip again there and that's just
not very efficient so browsers have sort
of not implemented that another reason
is that they don't run the reason to why
they don't support HTTP - over plain
plain text connections unencrypted like
at all it's because it's really
problematic to deploy that on the
Internet if you introduce this kind of
huge breaking changes like an entire new
protocol there is so much infrastructure
out there in terms of like proxy servers
they're called middle boxes in sort of
the the standard standard speak
there's so many middleboxes you know
there could be firewalls that could be
like logging servers on corporate
networks all kinds of optimizers caches
for like mobile phones that are
automatically transparently compressing
your images and sort of all this
infrastructure exists that makes it
impossible to really deploy things in
plain text because they assume that if
it's plain text that they can mess
around with it and they just end up
breaking HTTP to send it in plain text
because they they're built for I needs
to be one world and now alone they don't
recognize a protocol and updating all of
that stuff would basically be a
situation where you could never update
it because nobody would do it unless
there's an e to and it would only be
Neetu if everyone's already upgraded so
you get this chicken and egg thing and
that's why you can really only introduce
huge new protocol changes by fully
encrypting everything and saying only
like the slightest amount of bits in
that head you know the handshake excuse
me excuse me
okay so that's why we have to use HTTPS
to put a sir put it for the browser's to
actually support it now so curl and a
lot of other command tools they don't
really care about that they're just like
they're for debugging and the protocol
the spec actually the spec describes how
you can do it over TLS and I can do
without TLS and the specs it describes
like this upgrade mechanism so a lot of
these command-line tools they'll
actually support it node also note node
supports like we saw our plain text and
there's also a client built-in to the
node the node hpo information neck that
can connect to a plaintext to http to
server but that's really only useful for
like machine to machine like an API call
to another API call if you want to skip
over a nolte lasting or for for like
writing unit tests like if you're trying
to hit a server and you don't want to
set up like certificates self-signed
certificates and deal with all this
self-signed hassle on your CI server for
instance you can just make a plain text
connection to that so but in the real
world when you're dealing with users on
browsers you're gonna need TLS okay so
okay maybe before we add let's let's
compare with the the core API that we've
been using now with this stream we can
compare this to the compatibility API so
you notice here we've got still the same
create server but we're providing in a
callback right in the create server call
so in the first example we just did a
create server and we did not pass it any
callback right it just we get a return
value which immediately synchronously we
get this server object back the server
instance and then we attach an event
handler to stream now the the this this
is how you enable and this is a very
subtle way I'm not a big fan of it but
it this is a subtle way to enable
compatibility API by passing an event
handler to create server yeah this is
sort of the tricky part like so you
might do this by default because this is
generally how you handle requests on HP
one so you create server and you give it
a callback for any kind of it's a
request to call back right so the
request event so the request if
and in the core API we don't use that we
just use the stream event and we have a
session event also but we use a stream
event to deal with a request and we get
the headers and we didn't send the data
back on that stream but this request and
response objects are only part of the
compatibility API and these are the ones
that expose all of the there's sort of
the h3 one legacy API stuff they expose
all the same methods and properties like
I said and so if you pass this callback
in there you get a standard like I'm a
familiar request object on a familiar
response object and you can you can use
them too soon either the familiar API is
like right head with a number and then a
map of headers and then again you can
use a stream to just and to close it off
with a string part pass it about has it
back out so if you if you run this
you'll get more or less the same thing
but now using compatibility API if you
log like the request object you'll see
that looks very different from the
stream object so it has these different
properties the low-level ones are gonna
be on the stream and the high-level ones
are coming on request so one thing you
might be wondering is like okay what
well what if I have a request
and I want to access the lower-level
stuff locally that's just exposed
request dot stream and you get access to
the lower-level stuff again but you
might you can you can see how that could
be a slight hit on performance so if
you're going for like a benchmarking
tool some really high performance code
you might want to stick to the core API
without sort of the overhead of wrapping
all of these objects and doing that
extra parsing to expose a compatibility
layer but it's there so in most cases
you can just use the compatibility API
because if it gives you all of that
functionality of the middleware that
you're already using with with whatever
framework that you're on right now it
gives you all of that like
out-of-the-box pretty much works with
well I'm not gonna say it works with
everything but it works pretty well and
it's very familiar if you've got if
you've been using HTTP and on node for a
couple years then there's gonna be very
very familiar
HTTP to get the HTTP or snugfit I'm very
happy to a load test just on this to see
my Cohen's D because it's a stable
pattern that's right cool
okay so that make sense I mean okay feel
free to change the coder you had to
maybe this one run it and see what see
what happens
so
yeah oh by the way maybe I should
clarify this this little guy here it's
not an emoji
it's an ipv6 local address so the ipv4
would be like 127.0.0.1 and it would
ipv6 because the addresses are really
really long there's like this
abbreviated notation and and I'm like
the local host address essentially for
ipv6
it's just : : it's just completely
revered cool cool
but because the HTTP URL has like the
colon for your port you kind of have to
like wrap your ipv6 colon colon in these
square brackets so essentially this
becomes your hostname where this is the
IP address that the double colon is your
IP address and the square brackets is
better to like say this is the hostname
part of the URL and then the this colon
here 8080 is just a divider between the
port and a hostname the separator so
that's why you'll see this in a lot of
places and it's it trips it trips me up
many many times and I fix bugs and
people trimmer it's not like a lot where
I see people forgetting to actually wrap
them and you end up seeing URLs like
HTTP colon slash slash and then triple
colon and you're like what is the going
on here people forget about that all the
time it's annoying little gotcha
so I just wanted to put that in there to
make sure we everyone is aware of that
okay now so let's get on to why like
fixing this for the browser so TLS right
like I was saying the reason why we have
to use TLS is because of compatibility
really like it without here that's it
would just break we would never be able
to rule out HP 2 because it would be
trying to patch a huge change on to an
existing protocol there's massive
adoption and nobody would really want to
implement that so there's this chicken
and egg thing
so the spec allows plain text but you
really just want to use you really just
want to use it over TLS so the spec
actually refers to a TLS 1.3 and one in
one part in one place but TLS 1.3
doesn't officially exist yet and HTP to
spec came out a while ago they were very
optimistic that the TLS 1.3 would be
settled and they continue to be
optimistic and so like a month ago they
were they were saying oh we should we
should probably push back they were
thinking that will be out in March or
April this year but now it's probably
gonna get packed push back to like q3 q4
of this year and we'll see right so TLS
1.3 is a work in progress right now
we're on TLS 1.2 and despite the small
change in version number there's like 10
years of difference between them so
don't underestimate TLS one point three
is almost an entire new kind of protocol
then till that's one point two one of
the key changes right is the the sort of
the design of TLS in the past until up
and until including 1.2 was sort of this
layered approach of protocols so you
would first establish a TCP socket which
means that you send you send something
to the server to a syn packet and then
you get back this acknowledgment and you
would send back you know an
acknowledgment to the server again so
they'll be like this this this this
round-trip going on before you could
start your TLS handshake
now the TLS handshake is again the
client saying hey I want to do TLS and
in the server going ok these are the
certificates that I have and the
mechanisms that I support and in the
kline going back and saying here's ok
here's the one I want to use
and then sort of going okay now we're
now are connected now you can send your
request so but so we now have teal TCP
one one round trip and then TLS two more
round trips before we can even get into
that HTTP request that we actually just
want to send and so we're dealing with
minimum of four round trips which is
unacceptable in in most environments
that's very wasteful you should be able
to just transfer the whole thing and
that has been a design goal of quick
which is essentially the new sort of
transport layer for HTTP that replaces
this whole TCP TLS thing with a modular
approach where you would send a single
UDP Datagram that includes the quick
session negotiate anything that includes
your TLS 1.3 you know certificate
algorithm kind of selections as well as
your HTTP requests all in a single
Datagram so that goes out from the
client to the server and the server says
ok for quick we will do this for TLS 1 3
we will do that and here's your here's
your response for your request on HTTP
so you can get back the entire thing in
a single round trip and from then on
your server can you start pushing so you
never have to actually send out a sort
of a think time request were you waiting
for the server to respond so you you
could you get to completely eliminates
the wasted round trips that you would
have with us 1.2 so that's sort of where
that's going
I will say that neither neither quick
nor TLS 1.3 are like standardized right
now
but if you open up your browser
inspector you'll see that when you
connect to Google comm or YouTube or
something or or maybe even some Facebook
sites you'll see that these guys are
already playing around with it
yeah even some CD ends like cloud 4 day
and they'll once in awhile you'll see
them announced that ode if they store -
that's 1.3 don't worry it's all works
what they support is maybe more like gee
quick or gee TLS 123 or well like draft
versions of TLS 1.3 and earlier versions
of quick were sort of published by
Google because what that research was
was it was originally done there before
moved into the IETF working group didn't
you want to make a statement or
all right
don't get like struck by lightning on
the beach party up by yourself or
something you know yeah okay that's a
little bit of a background and you know
what's going to happen soon with quick
and http2 and TLS here's some of the
things that we're using from HTTP from
from TLS 1.2 right now to make this HTTP
2 stuff work and some of the things that
you can use to make it even better so
alpine if you saw the curl debug stuff
this al pn alpine this is what it what
it's using to connect to the server and
figure out whether this HTTP URL is
using HTTP 2 or HTTP 1 so because
because of this stack or this layered
approach there's first as TCP connection
handshake this round-trip when it does
the first round trip when the client
makes the first round trip of the TLS
handshake it basically includes a little
little bit of information that says I
support HTTP 2 but I also support HTTP
1.1 the server receives this in the
initial handshake and says ok I'm gonna
serve you HP 10.1 or I'm going to serve
you HP 2 so this that's that's really
the handshake that's called alpine and
in node that's now exposed with a simple
property called allow HTTP 1 so this
defaults to false you have to actually
opt in to the backwards compatibility I
forget why we made it false by default
so basically I have to like pretty much
always that Disqus yeah I would like I
think by default you would want to have
its be 1.1 backwards compatibility it
seems like a good idea but you know you
can you could leave it turn it off if
you maybe like a year from now you go
like whatever it works everywhere it's
fine so that's that's one that's one
mechanism that were using you you you
might come across this name so now you
can sound smart and talk about it
SNI another one that's the server name
identification SNI is basically how you
put a lot of different host names on
single single host on a single IP
address HP one would use the host header
for that I think it's actually HTTP 1.1
that introduced it HP 1.0 you still had
like I'd have like one IP address for
one server because when you connect to a
server you
like I want this record I have this path
name that I want to request with this
method but the server wouldn't know
which domain you're requesting it from
so it would have to say okay this IP
address I'm receiving this connection on
that's configured to be dis hostname and
with HP one point one they were like
okay okay this is getting expensive to
like maintain all these different IP
addresses and so they introduced this
host header host : and an example net
alright that's that's the domain I wanna
connect to and let's say that you're
hosting your thing uh many many many
websites on your shared server like
cheap hosting or like you know you pay
like a dollar a month for your website
hosting they'll basically be one server
with one IP address that hosts ten
thousand websites right they rely on
that host header to map like your
request to the correct set of files to
serve or to correct PHP to quote the run
or whatever you want to do so in HTTP to
that's happening like a step earlier at
the TLS level the TLS 1.2 has this
extension called sni the server name
identification which you can use now
into your to serve the correct
certificate because you can't even get
the request yet you don't get that host
header you know about it before you get
to serve your certificate so when you
have a lot of hosts on one server you
need to consider that they would all be
they might all have a different
certificate or TLS certificate you don't
want to have like the same certificate
for a hundred sites if that gets
compromised then you're in a whole
buncha trouble if you either revoke it
you mender provoking everyone at the
same time so there's complexities there
and the reasons why you would not want
to limit the number of hosts domain
names on a single certificate so you
need to be able to figure out which
certificate to serve to the request
before you get to the HTTP level that's
why we use this thing called sni to say
okay we've I'm gonna give you this
certificate at the handshake level of
TLS level then later in the HTTP 2 level
there's no more a hosts header now that
was deprecated and turned into the
authority pseudo header this quona
thority so that's where like I get that
confused a lot of times host origin
Authority I kind of like mix the mix
them up mix and match them a little bit
too many times but basically okay Alpine
s and I and then the last one I want to
show is a OCSP
this is okay what is Oh again
certificate stapling protocol like
offline maybe or something I don't know
essentially what okay so one problem is
that when you issue a certificate to a
for your domain you get a certificate
from a from a certificate authority and
then you go to your web host and you
give them a certificate to serve your
content on your domain maybe at some
point you you save that and like sort of
an insecure location on the computer
that got hacked or you leaked it somehow
and you need to revoke that certificate
sure you could go and take it down from
the web side you get a new certificate
and upload it to your web server but
everyone else might might still have
that certificate right and you need to
be able to tell them hey this this is no
longer valid stop using it please and so
what's happening is that the certificate
itself includes a URL where the client
can verify with the certificate
authority whether or not this is still
valid or with or is it on a revoke asian
list so whenever you make a connection
to a web server your client your
browsers can actually make a make a do
and do an extra check and again this is
a round trip that your that's happening
as delaying your load time and so
there's a protocol called OCSP that's
called staples it basically staples that
response onto the certificate as it's
being served to the client and so
stapling means that the server the web
server itself actually periodically goes
and gets the latest sort of validity
result and just staples it on so rather
than every single browser making those
calls like if you have a huge website
and you have every single browser
hitting that certificate authority
they're gonna suffer like they need this
stuff a huge amount of structure just to
handle these revocation checks and so
it's better that the web server itself
just periodically checks it and includes
it sticks it on to that certificate and
and gives it to the client where the
client and goes like okay this is still
recent enough for me to consider it as
non revoked and it also eliminates that
roundtrip
it so that it eliminates a round trip
for the for that client so it doesn't
need to like make another connection to
another so host and do another DNS
lookup because that could be very
expensive so it's faster and it's less
load on to see
a server so it's cheaper so it's just
generally better to do this but by
default this is actually turned off in
all node server to TLS so you need to do
a little bit of code to make this work
so I'll show you from one of my projects
how I do that if you ever need to
reference it just you know look at this
as an example I'm by the way I'm using
this thing called just require OCSP okay
and then I build a cache and I basically
this is basically a snippet from the
make it a little bigger okay so the OCSP
cache is essentially what I'm using to
store the certificates that I've got up
them to look up for right so whenever I
get a request my server fight fires this
event this is a standard TLS note event
this is not new - this is not new in an
HTTP - this is if you're using HTTP
right now you could get this event and
your problem if you're not handling it
right now you're wasting all these round
trips and your users are making all
these extra calls so if you just want to
improve the performance of like a
standard HTTP you should still do this
right now basically this is like caching
the responses as they come back your
server makes that request to look it up
if it doesn't have a currently valid
it's the sort of stapled response and
otherwise it pulls it out of a cache and
service directly so it's really fast
this is the big concept sort of stapling
make sense now a little bit okay all
right so question now is how do we do
this localhost certificate I had this
for a long time now I've had a bit I've
had like some well it started with like
just going in a stack overflow every
time and trying to find the right copy
paste open SSL command line stuff
it's very TV so I started automating it
and I just last night to make this
easier here I publish this TLS keygen on
NPM so you should be able to just
generate it by running that on your
system it'll just generate a key up em
and a cert them and and it'll try if
you're on Mac or Linux not Windows sorry
but cuz I didn't have any machine to
test it on yet it will try to sort of
set it up on your computer so that your
computer trusts it and that's very
convenient if you didn't like local
development then your browser is not
gonna show you those like security
content warnings and I get really
annoying when you try to do anything in
the browser basically so you can you can
use this tool to generate a certificate
I have a trusted and then you use those
certificates on any software that you
that you're working with in ojs we TLS a
couple of things that it does just to
give you like some insights into TLS
itself the tool that you're using is
open SSL so most of you will have that
installed already if not ruined brew
install or you know more apt-get or
whatever this got this thing called san
service alternate names I think subject
thank you okay so subject alternate
names basically I the certificate can
have a single common name the CN that we
saw which describes the the domain name
for the certificate but over time people
are like okay well I want to have like a
bunch more names and in wildcard names
and IP addresses and all kinds of things
and so this this extension was added to
tier two certificates where you can then
describe a bunch more domain names and
it'll all get signed on one certificate
it's very convenient when you want to
have like your example.com and then your
wwwww example.com on one certificate
right instead of having two so when
you're reconnect you can reuse it
so basically this tool sets it up so
that you have local host you have
wildcard local host you have like one
two seven zero zero one you have your
ipv6 I have zero zero zero zero like all
your like local stuff and it the same
certificate works for any of them so
when you go into the browser even if the
remember like okay is it is it 1 2 7 or
is it localhost and then if you want to
experiment experiment with like
different domain names you can just do
something something dot localhost and
you can set it up in your at C it's the
hosts file to the same so to your local
host and it'll all resolve which is
critic valid certificate then also it's
using ECC which is like elliptic curve
cryptography no I'm not a cryptographer
but usually when you see smaller numbers
it means less secure but with with
typical 2's certificates and you would
have this RSA 2048 or 4096 or whatever
you have these big big numbers the
reason there's a big name is because the
certificates actually that size is that
many bits and in this case you own you
can achieve similar levels of security
with only 256 bits using this elliptic
curve cryptography stuff so that's
really nice and it's actually
recommended at by some US government
thing n ist some you know in whatever
standards technology whatever stuff they
recommend like these basically the
baselines for what level of security do
you need for for their operations and
this is sort of generally accepted in
the industry as like whatever what
people use on the Internet and so right
now if you're using like RSA 200 2048
you can just use this the this this this
elliptic this ECC be 2 5 6 or p-38 for
this is slightly larger in terms of key
but I think they're kind of rating them
as prints the same in terms of security
strength and so P 2 5 6 is more
supported there have been issues in the
past where people 3 8 4 was I think it
was like nodes versions 9.0 to nine
point two or three it was like
temporarily not supported now I came
back so it's a little bit of a pain if
you want to just feel like okay this is
a bigger number I want to use that go
for it but this is still a sufficient
the real risk is not even like we have
to go bigger there's a whole nother
different curve now coming out because
there's some weird speculation and stuff
going on like this might be compromised
and NSA will like break it and whatever
I know I don't think they're gonna come
after Cooper yes but if your website is
like super important and you might have
to worry about that there so anyway
there's these are called curves these
are like close short codes for curves
and there's a new curve coming out I
forget what's like like x.25 five
something something something so but
that's all still going through ITF
process and reviewing and the pics that
takes a long time for a get adoption so
you could use it but it's probably gonna
work in most browsers so these like I
would say stick with P 2 5 6 or RSA 2048
if you want to be compatible and well
supported today so this tool basically
does that for you so try it out right
now this is gonna help you with like
general development run npx TLS - qijin
and see what happens
it's quite untested so I want to see I
wanna hear what goes wrong sure
syntax error so yeah so I think house
you could you could you could just say
fubar look closed yeah so but the
certificates a wild card so it'll
validate that in theory script at the
command txt rescue June hey can you do
no - Peters
hmm [ __ ] [ __ ] seems like there's a
syntax or set can anyone confirm that
okay okay sorry let me look
[Music]
what's the line is it touch file in mine
mine one
does it say the filename
what am I not seeing you think there's a
there's a typo here
no it's just restructuring it 9 4 0 okay
so yeah I mean you can you could take a
snippet and run it like you're why is it
was it wrong and you won't see the issue
absolutely
where's that okay oh yeah I was just
doing that to escape these bracket the
other quotes
runs on my machine hmm let me see let me
see if it runs on the this guy to this
kitchen
Oh
that's a weird one more chairs at the
back apparently you don't expect a token
parentis
for Rebecca
right
I know yeah I'm just yeah
tried tried it okay can you can can
anyone try to do npm install like dev
let's see that let's see okay so yeah
okay let me try
I'm just again stalling it in my local
directory now the workspace that we had
and then to your last keygen yeah that's
funny okay
Oh
hmm
no you said yeah right
[Music]
booter so if okay so okay we can just
run it directly than you're saying
so if you just do note
okay so alright so sorry about this
weirdness I'm not entirely sure what's
going on I have a hint
but anyway run it this way just run npm
install and let me see you do npm
install - uppercase D TLS - keygen
that'll set it up as a local dev
dependency and then you do node and in
your node modules TLS - keygen CL I
guess it's funny from the bin it fails
but it's exactly the same file
okay so
so solar system didn't detect this as a
attract process thank you thank you
thank you
I know what's the standard one like that
okay
hey thank you okay so you can just do
the npx kiosk ijen right now it should
be fixed okay
so has anyone managed to generate a key
in a certificate and then gone through
the sudo thing and all that yeah it
worked
yeah yeah okay so you can you can verify
whether or not that actually did
anything just so you know I'm not like
stealing everyone's passwords here open
up this keychain access tool on Mac at
least on Linux I'm not too sure you can
essentially see if you search for
localhost they should have some
certificates here passports why am i
talking about certificates yeah
so I use this I use this thing a lot
like this technique a lot so I've got a
bunch of them you should have at least
one here has anyone seen that okay you
so if you ever need to do this manually
this is what you do you just drag the
certificate file onto this keychain
access thing you double-click on the PEM
file and for SSL on trust settings you
just put on always trust and from that
moment on most software that integrates
well with Mac OS like Chrome browser or
Safari they will just trust that
certificate for connections that are on
this for domains that are on this
certificate so you can see for instance
in this case it would be localhost plus
the wildcards plus my local IP address
etc so these kind of this this is like
now a certificate that I can use with
software without having to face like all
these browser issues so the TLS keygen
tool just automates as much as possible
there
a little bit yeah that's why I'm doing
this in a module name we'll just be like
look closed and these are just
concatenated with semicolon
you look I can generate is the OpenSSL
command on your systems
using the shell and what is it so can
you try it in a regular standard
terminal thing without over like this
item - or something right because I
think when node runs it it's just
running it in plain bash right I'm not
too sure but he's also got like a funky
pin terminal like that mine's very
vanilla it was I terminal well what node
version is this one because any nines
enough nvm anymore
hey you got it right okay so it runs
here okay then oh wait that's it so this
part is fine right but I gotta do p.m.
perm keep him in search firm you know
none of that that's normal actually
so that's actually a help message wait
was that the whole thing the whole time
no just type
Quintanilla okay that was really my
baddest bad UX right there
welcome thank one second I gotta save
him okay can you show me the commanding
in that you're right the CLI right
you know when you run the when you're in
school I don't yes because they simply
they switched over to the regular
terminal or didn't they also I think I
forgot to note right rifle track I want
to just see first okay you know that
just seems too often did they just
forgot it to the key dopamine circuit
them you know that's different first
room I haven't tried out
Ron she is just directly
could be something there as well John
for the open come install on that thing
I guess
that's the stenciling all mogul
every reading so yeah that's like the
file is there I don't know if it just
wasn't generated or if it's in the wrong
location
does anyone else get this one doesn't
okay yeah yeah okay sorry this is like
my really bad UX your basically has you
have to supply this part okay yeah
basically
okay that's his promise oh he's got the
same issue
can you try running in the regular
terminal and then make sure you have not
like node 9 point 4 yeah that's good
it's time all right so he's working on
bugging it also for them yeah yeah so
now we've got two cases of that
so it says that they can't find the key
file hit search file which one you know
the search file
yeah can you try to making it like a
like an absolute path to what is it on
there now seeing the full thing they're
reading so can you open up that code and
then go to setup fearless
okay so actually what I want to see
right like it's one sink
so what we want to see is like this
whole thing what's actually happening
because he's trying to deconstruct this
now because it's got like some semester
shells and like nesting bird investors
and of yourself I'm wondering if it's
good because I'm setting the shelter
banner oh you know what you're using a
fish or something or the Sh
using some panel because you guys all
have like interesting shells
I'm gonna maybe not yeah no I don't know
this is tricky man this is for updated
Oh
yeah maybe hang on maybe maybe a you
know I see era
he's got Yosemite just like think around
the same era yeah yeah
so because I've only tested in High
Sierra good issue there maybe the open
maybe the OpenSSL syntax changed can you
update open SSL somehow because I don't
ask you to update always I just like as
an experiment to try with open SSL and
later version mmm open open side of
field us right now right now that set up
to us we have set up filters in your
code right did you assert the javascript
file for set up realistic the teskigi
anything
yeah can you switch this on new king
RSA yes which is on and switched it off
because maybe it's just like not
supporting GCC
just missing my together it is so much
on our side for mismatch is it something
or in my most welcome because I'm not
sure what we actually doing this
three-step
okay chewing the website the browser via
keep touching it to look lost eight four
four three side come from ice cream
should be supported through the cones
okay can I see your how are you running
that one doesn't know your snippet Asia
running yeah
okay so it's is there anything else
running right now I know of at least on
hot eight four four three
you sure can look you on that's that
that's that - am i and is there any
there's a search or something
something's listening okay okay so it's
okay okay this guy's in cannot support
protocol
still something to do in this step as I
get it it's been directly no yeah I can
do X which I mean my host file is a
little bit nicer yeah that's fine that's
fine
I mean you shouldn't even have needed it
because you're you you work for Sephora
cool oops
hey Yvonne Yvonne think she's a designer
there oh I was just gonna if you just
use localhost you should need it
actually it's only I could want to set
up like subdomain some local kind of
like what you were doing there but this
one what does that last line comment on
all right over go don't you I can see
you had a very rough night
I for one in years to come you know Ruth
that's pretty much
but that guy so long here with me should
get it working nice yeah yeah but this
is the thing with like experimental
stuff if there's so many educational
platforms I have not you're gonna find
out only be the keys that I have
generate that up can you open up the
Keith I think W is double-click up with
the cert class and I mean finder so open
up here and I don't think it's down and
it just doesn't stroll to the correct
one so it's search for localhost me you
don't have it set up at all try to try
to drag it in here so is there a way to
add it unless this key is not generated
hopefully the way I change the quickly
going this I just need to stay home
Frank open some windows
Siena changed location change location
what is it call now
is that so damn does okay yeah mom
so you gotta find somehow okay if you
look at it let me know man no this is oh
you gotta phone group yeah I did not
know how did you generate the configure
because I thought that was like a system
thing it seems like every system I tried
it had it like Linux Mac so it might be
like a recent thing you got it from user
local that's that's homebrew right yeah
okay I'll have to put a fallback that
one can you maybe make a issue on this
out this is one my Mac thing yeah but
somehow supplying that one I think this
one is from Mac on our coins yeah
whichever one your is it not just
assembling
I know if you can you can cut them just
to simply see what see if there's any
obvious defense it's big file tsa
convict what the heck open your luggage
with this thing it's a separate file
open the file size of difference oops
eleventy be kind of roughed in okay okay
this is cool
how did you find it locate the open
ancestors and does it does it work now I
recommend with you when you change the
path this should be good who had the
issue with Mavericks or was it yeah yeah
yeah Capitan but it seems like there's
okay it seems like he's got a solution
so the command itself pulls up a default
configuration and in here so it pulls up
this country and this location seems
have changed from the previous one so
you search for do a to turn or do a
terminal thing and just do like locate
open so that's enough
okay I don't know how you did that yeah
exactly
[Music]
I was just get I wasn't asking for them
could you help him he's trying to find
the file here's another look II think
you are working no how about here
HD dress awesome okay you're skipping
ahead frameworks and although you can go
for it sorry it's just like weird
compatibility she's faster fire is
amazing I started using it like last
year like mid last year whatever when I
first came out I was like fixing bugs
all the time like he's like reviewing my
code it's good nice like I finally get
to meet him you expressed I think
there's still some issues expressed like
the project is kind of stale and there I
mean like there was always they do some
hacky stuff with the with the the the
way that they wrapped the put the
request and the response objects that
they get from node if you want and it
doesn't work anymore but hb2 it's like
some like doing things that the internal
stone is like not using the official API
and those things all broke so we've been
trying to work with the guy
his name Doug Doug Wilson trying to tell
him like trying to fix these things yeah
yeah and he he knows he's aware of those
things but it's just like here's another
time to commit to fixing its breasts
which is kind of sad because millions of
people using adventure yeah so I
personally I was using connect for a
long time and now for my new stuff I
always use past if I what depends are
connectors like more low level high
performance stuff mystic would connect
you can use the middlewares but nothing
too fanciful well then fast if I get all
this cool stuff work building API it's
just the best thing ever so I put like a
bunch of examples here usually I go
through it and see how I was using
schema I was doing the fallback and the
configuring of like we routes and all
that it's a really cool tool is working
on both systems now all right good good
good how about it how about here
is there a can I ask at what point you
get stuck or did you already good
question I just sold out something I'm
sorry sorry it's a bit like yeah it's a
big classroom let's yeah no no it's not
about anyone's Paul Facebook I'm curious
like you we're able to like run it at
all this is this is window so I'm also
not sure how things go there so what
happens for some of them was the same
issue like they were like I'm an older
version of Mac and it didn't work right
and if you if you actually look at the
source code of the school right it's
basically just calling open SSL on the
command line so if you're able to open
this all up in a cell you can actually
use that as well just like all it's
doing is like sort of abstracting over
it but it's kinda interesting cuz like
if you ever need this open SSL command
you just couldn't come up with your own
fix for it and I would I would love a
pull request for Windows I need how's it
going
our context and here's the dried fish
and I'm trying to fast if I didn't
perform a boost test with the 10,000
cool three times
requests per second Oh whereas this guy
he had a decrease
what compared to what I gave you two
versus if you wanted yeah the tls versus
mean just using faster five versus just
using HTTP okay both of you - yeah and
then what versus what the FASTA file is
a framework that's on top of the native
edge to be doing I wasn't there but in
order to make it even faster so I guess
these talking about there but the way
the thing that is really better at is
the damage sort of a JSON generator
there's a it's like one of the
dependencies of Festiva is this like
thing that just generates JSON and
generates those strings faster than the
json stringify
and that's one thing where it speeds up
and one of the reasons they can do that
is because they use the schema that you
can supply to precalculate like you pre
generate a function that just statically
like it basically decree it from the
schema create a function that you give
it input it is create strings of those
lengths right and you avoid a lot of
like internal like allocating
reallocating of string when you
concatenate stuff
and this is one thing we're nude sort of
has internally like this concept of
there's two kinds of strings and when it
switches from one to the other
s like reallocate all that memory or
when a string goes beyond the boundary
has to grow and like reallocate a much
memory and a couple of times when you'd
like generating a large JSON response
that can really slow things down and so
the way he set it up it sort of tricks
node into following the correct path
straight away rather than stumbling
until we find the solution this is one
thing where the committee faster yeah
this would this people straight like to
stand standard this is not like I
perform more than anything like that
this is more like showing you can do
standard streaming stuff yeah actually
there's a cool API called respond with
file descriptor if you go to the API
documentation right this is what I mean
for like serving static content and even
the FASTA file static middleware uses it
as well okay so this is an API that's
only in H to be to you know down like it
lets the ng HTTP to library it's off at
the C level like just deal with the file
handling note can open a file file
descriptor and pass it to ng hb2 and
it'll do it so they'll avoid a lot of
buffer copying in memory it's not even
piping there's many piping like piping
we mean that goes to node and we notice
the copy buffers around this is just
like just see library do the thing
here's a fly descriptor and I think it
is the OS doing an essentially at that
point yeah so you avoid a lot of so if
you go for like really high throughput
that's actually what you can do to make
it a little faster but discussion about
this yesterday
my Pradas be we have a bunch of
Microsoft said oh now we have varnish
okay and we have a cougar
Express server yeah right at the back
girl
yeah could make any sense it mauritius
around
it doesn't die in force understand it
doesn't actually sweetie right yeah good
point I mean that's actual what most
students do then you lose the ability to
do push streams then you lose the
ability to do all the features yeah but
if you look at the back end and you have
a varnish or nginx or anything and
actually or whatever proxying you lose
the edge spew aside from the from the
back end because they only talk upstream
to sp1 yes so what they use for that is
the link preload header most of the
students and most of the using peanuts
no it's you can do that for a couple of
requests but you can't like push a huge
bunch of like a whole bunch of push push
promises I've been actually playing
around with that one like from a
front-end developer background I wanted
to just like do bundling with my server
push and none of none of the none of
these link preload solutions which would
accommodate that because they like they
don't compress that Harrier properly
they kind of do it on the plane I guess
but just like the limits on like how
many you can do a push like a thousand
little JavaScript and CSS files which
like you know that's a standard from an
application these days it's just like
people don't see it because it's a big
web pack bundle but if you deconstruct
it into like its original parts then
that would actually be like a thousand
please promises and relate to be -
that's not a problem the protocol is
totally capable of that this is the most
observers kind of choke
when the caching is actually now
different because you can have cash not
just like a huge asset you can cash to
each of these individual components so
actually maybe I should talk about that
because I have a section on that
okay so most people have managed to get
it working I hope sorry about all the
compatibility issues with various shells
and various operating systems and
versions of Mac OS and all that but it
was a great exercise I think we so I
think probably also again a lot of
people have skipped ahead to checking
out some of these frameworks fast if I
many of you were at Mateos workshop so
you probably know more about it than I
do now testify a great framework for
working relates to b2 because it
supports it out of the box now and you
can use this with your Express
middleware it's fast and all that like
there's a whole bunch of marketing hype
okay don't use a framework because it
says it's fast use it because you
because it works and does its job for
you whatever it is if your job
relies on you serving JSON output you
know 10% faster then just get a bigger
server or something
it's like it
my personal preference for using fast fi
is that it's a very nice API it does the
async/await stuff it makes my code more
enjoyable to write and to read and
that's my primary reason if I want to
make it actually like serve way more
requests I would probably look at very
different strategies than just changing
a framework and hoping for some silver
bullet but that's just you know I don't
want to I love that's why it's my by far
my favorite choice and I would use it
over express any day because it's just
more up to date but if you want to
compare like benchmarks and all that
kind of stuff it's just not really that
high of a priority for me personally not
to say that it isn't actually the
fastest thing also so yeah I put a
little example in there like that shows
some of the ways that you use it but
again you guys probably already have
gone through that this morning the only
thing that's relevant to HP to you is
that you basically just set it to be too
true and you're good to go
in HTTP options where you provide your
crypto stuff you also just say allow
HTTP 1 and it does the Alpine
negotiating thing automatically so
you've seen all this schema stuff
basically for those who were not at that
workshop FASTA fire has a couple of cool
features
beyond what like Express is typically
capable of for instance middlewares
and and and request handlers can be
asynchronous functions out-of-the-box
like he work with Cola or I think happy
maybe they kind of support these things
as well so you you can normally use a
response object to sort of send output
with FASTA file it's called the reply
object and you have a slightly different
API but it it's pretty pretty simple you
just go reply and then send some stuff
and by default it's really good at doing
JSON it's all set up for JSON so the
incoming request is expecting to be like
if you do a post to a festivai server
without configuration you should just
give it a content type application JSON
because this element expects JSON like
it's just really convenient for modern
applications you don't have to like
configure all these things per route
anymore on the output you can set things
like a schema like a response schema for
like a 200 response I'm expecting it to
have a this to be of type object it
could be type arrayed it could be type
string whatever as long as it's valid
JSON you describe it with this JSON
schema which is this back JSON schema
org there's a format that a lot of
different projects are using I use this
for other things as well but like fast
if I use it to describe what is allowed
or not allowed in for instance this
output this is response of a 200 but it
can also use it for like tweaking
filtering out the valid versus invalid
query string parameters or request
payloads and all these kind of things so
it's it's a really nice it's a nice to
have it's optional you don't have to you
set this all up but in this case I'm
using it for convenience that I can make
sure that only the node and the v8
properties are being output because my
handler this is the request handler
right it it just returns processed out
versions and the process of versions
actually contains a lot more than just
than just this node and v8 property it
contains a whole bunch of other things
but my output I'll be guaranteed that
it'll only contain node and v8 it has a
nice side effect of if he provides FEMA
it actually makes faster fire faster
because I can compile a function that
just serializes your object into a
string in one shot but it's it's great
in cases where you're let's say you're
using MongoDB you make a query to your
database so you get back some some some
some row from your database
you just output it by doing like your
just return the output actually return
to promise to get the output so you can
do this whole thing without like with
with a lot less code right you just have
an async function that returns your
[ __ ] query and if you set the schema it
will filter out things like that
underscore ID these kind of pesky little
things that have to deal with otherwise
all that I'll let you know pointless
code just skip it just specify what you
need to get done and pacify takes care
of it so a lot of these nice things I
really like about Festa Phi so I would
use it for done so but yeah and take a
look at Festa Phi if that's your thing
go for it
things like error handling is also taken
care if you can you can set up schemas
for your errors and stuff like that you
can you don't even have to actually
explicitly send an error you can just
throw an error so this is the nice way
to dealing with async functions if you
have a promise that may may may throw an
error who cares it'll just show a nice
error message to the user and you don't
have to write like I always try caches
and all this stuff so really convenient
modern code in north esta fire ok load
testing we kind of covered enough of
that thanks for killing my server again
that's ok you know makes it stronger and
by the way by the time I fix it
coalescing connections talked a lot
about that so I wanted to do example I
really did this is something that has
come out like like last week in node 9
point 4 and it's been on my to-do list
for a long time to actually get this
working it would be amazing I tried
playing with it for a few days and I
just couldn't get the API working
correctly it may be a it may be a
browser issue that no browser actually
supports this right now but it's yeah
sorry I couldn't actually get this
example working but the concept is there
and this will get implemented going
forward by all browsers and everyone
else so a lot of tools can start using
these CDNs will start offering these
features there's more going on than just
what's currently supported in node which
is the alternative service ring which
has this origin concept so the server
basically when a client connects to a
server to request example.com
it can say I also serve food command bar
comm and send those as origin frames to
the client so that the client then knows
like ok if if I do a DNS lookup for
those domains and they match and it
the certificate that's being used for
this connection matches then I can reuse
this HP to session to open streams to
various servers on that same session so
that's the concept but this is very new
and experimental stuff so there's still
things evolving and people are trying to
make it better for instance now there's
a lot of discussion in the last few
months about secondary certificates this
is a proposal I think by people from
Akamai or Microsoft or whoever secondary
certificates would be you connect with
TLS to a host right you get a
certificate back and then the server can
send additional certificates so if you
combine that like if you say like this
there's another certificate it comes in
for this at this this extra domain that
I want to connect to and the server also
declares its origin is supported on it
on the thing then the server can then
serve with any certificate later on like
this could be not just at the initial
handshake but it could be further down
and when the server knows that now you
can add it now you're gonna to make this
you know extra request to a different
origin I'm gonna serve that as well Oh
additionally in terms of privacy this
could be quite important with TLS
there's certain things that are
protected and certain things that are
not protected right so for instance if
you connect to a server if you connect
to you know my spy server dot whatever
people who are snooping on that your ISP
or you know your your your government
agency or whatever they could they would
see which push you're connecting to
they could not see what's in your
request so they can't see you know the
path name of the request because that's
already encrypted if you're able to use
secondary certificates you could connect
to you know my generic service and then
follow that up with a request to my
secret-spy server right that would
improve your privacy because you're
using your view by the time you send
that second request it's already fully
fully encrypted and you can use those
additional certificates and they would
be none the wiser anyone who's spying
logging that connection could never
under Section happening beyond that
first connection they only see that
first handshake so that's do some VPN
service or some privacy protection
service and that's all they would see
that you're using such a service but
they would not see what you're actually
requesting right now you can actually
see that unless like
we refuse VPNs for that this essentially
is the benefits of a VPN but in in
standard TLS on every web server and
every CDN so those are some of the
concepts that are being moved towards
and like yeah I haven't been able to get
it fully working yet so I'll rather
focus maybe a little bit more the time
we have on server push so we've seen
some of the the frames that were being
sent in the low-level stuff that we
looked at the protocol packets and all
that so those we saw data frames we saw
header frames we saw settings frames
there's another frame called a push
promise it's very similar to a header
frame in fact it contains almost exactly
the same information with a slight tweak
it also declares a there's a sort of the
ID of a stream that it will use it has
the intention to use in the future
hence the promise so it basically
reserves a stream by ID for future use
so the server sends this saying like
okay stream number 27 I'm gonna use it
to send the response to these headers
right so that's interesting to think
about the response to headers the
headers represent a request so the
server is sending the client a request
that's weird right like so normally the
client sends a request to the server and
the server responds order with it with
the response and each of these headers
and then each of these can have a body
write request kind of a body write like
if you do a post or a put or a patch or
something so but in this case it's
purely originating from the server
sending a request to the client and then
sending a response to the client so the
reason for this request being going out
from the server is that it has to say it
has to tell the client enough
information about the request so that
the client can then determine when it
when the time comes to actually make
such a request whether or not it matches
the promised stream and then it can skip
the actual request going out it can just
wait for it to come back ok so an
example might clarify that a little bit
if if asserts gzip but not brutally the
server might send a promise for a
encoded asset the client can then say ok
this response is gonna come come to me
but I can't use it because I don't
understand this this content encoding so
I'm just gonna go and request it anyway
so you know it might be the same URL to
the same asset but in encoding it could
consider that as unsupported and just
try to it'll just reset that that stream
it will cancel that and it'll make the
request anyway so that's why you might
want to set things in that initial
request that's coming in that push
promise to have different meanings to
the client right now though none of the
browser's really care about the headers
that you're sending so there's things
like the very header where you can tell
like caches or browsers whether a
response from the same path is actually
different or not in which ways it's
different depending on which headers
right now that's completely ignored when
you when you do a push it's very easy
the browser just looks at the the the
path name and if it's the correct path
in of the door class that it's going to
make it'll except it'll wait for it if
it's different it'll make its own
request anyway so it's a very simple
even planation but that will change so
there's always already been declarations
of intent by I think chrome to say that
we will respect the very header in push
promises but I'm so I'm not sure if it's
currently in canary or anything like
that
but just be aware that that could be a
thing so most of the time your push
promise includes very little it's just
the path name and maybe a mime type or
something like if you want to do that
but it's very very bare minimal a kind
of request request that you're sending
it into motion and a push promise so I'm
using this personally for building web
apps and sort of bundling JavaScript and
CSS and fonts and whatever so that I
don't have to use like client-side
bundling tools like all these build
tools like web pack I'd rather not have
to use that I'd rather do that at a
protocol level one reason is that
because it just makes my life easier I
don't have to setup this you know I
don't have come up with a web pack
configuration every little project that
I do right it also benefits because you
can do this even earlier than like a web
pack with a pack if you have a bundle
then okay you have this wasted
round-trip still going on because you
first have to know that HTML before
I can actually even request that bundle
so with push you eliminate that because
as soon as you send your in HTML you can
already start sending all your
JavaScript on everything that mix then
your TCP connection ramps up faster and
you don't have to deal with like
specifics of like only the JavaScript
and then the CSS you can also just have
JavaScript import other JavaScript
import or CSS files employerís easily
import and not have to wait for a
roundtrip at each stage because it's
already being pushed so I'll show an
example of how I'm doing that this is a
quick like proof of concept kind of
exercise here I'll just go through it
real quick so we can get to my meme
something more interesting right now
we've got a secure server which we
understand and then we look at the HTTP
version for some reason okay what we
have to look at is a whether or not the
client allows push so if your connects
with like curl or ng HTTP they they have
a setting that the court that they sent
to the server the client setting that
this allows push and so if the server
were to actually send a push promise it
would be considered a connection
protocol err they will kill the
connection and so you don't want that to
happen all the time right it's kind of a
bad behavior
there could be legitimate reasons why a
browser may switch off push I don't know
of any browser that does that I run the
command line testing tools but so you
have to respect that still has to be
complying with the protocol so you kind
of always check because we're using
compatibility layer there's this whole
roundabout way of getting to the remote
settings and then figuring out does it
have an able push set to true so this
enable push true that's ultimately the
flag that you're looking for and when it
does you can use the API that's exposed
on the stream instanced to send the
request headers so this is the server
sending this fake request to the client
and in this case all I'm sending is a
simple path saying this is my dependency
okay and it it receives a push stream
and this is actually sort of the
response to the fake request right so
in terms of the protocol they see on the
wire this call to push stream here with
these headers this is the push promise
frame this is the push promise frame
that's going out and until you do
something with this push stream object
nothing's gonna happen so you can use
this to kind of cleverly sort and rank
how you actually emit your information
typically what I what I do and what I
think is sort of a good practice is you
you receive a request you serve you send
all of the push promises then you
respond to the original request with the
headers and the data frames and then you
start fulfilling all of those promises
with their response headers and their
data the reason is that the earlier you
send the response to the original
request let's it's typically that your
HTML the sooner the browser can start
working with that and building the DOM
and you know start scaffolding and
everything out but you need to send the
push promises first because otherwise it
may still make those requests because it
hasn't it doesn't know it's not aware
that they these push promises exist
right that you intend to send that so
you might send a request out so the push
promises first then the response to your
main request and then all the responses
to the push promises that's sort of the
typical order that I've been playing
with and it works very well now in this
case what we're gonna see okay push
dependencies okay so if we run that
Oh wrong directory we weren't
six
yeah of course really living here
okay so I've spun up the exercises as
displayed and I'm going to now okay so
what we see here is two requests one for
slash and one for the favicon however it
might not have had this open okay hang
on
reset okay we see two requests but we
see four requests in here okay so what
happened we see four requests from the
browser and okay okay they're served
from push so what is shown here protocol
h2 in this initiator problem you can
tell whether or not it's being served
from the push cache or not
so effectively only disk cache this
requests this this the root index.html
went out and our five icon so the round
trips were avoided completely in serving
this you know demo page and could prove
that by showing that the console indeed
logged hello world which came from a
dependency to a script file that was
being included so normally there would
be two round-trips and in this case it
was zero round trips like wasted so
that's the proof of concept of like how
can you use to bundle an entire
JavaScript application with zero
configuration or build tools of course
the question is you know I don't have
the code like each of my jobs good
assets into this
so there's tools around that that can be
developed I've been working on some
there's a lot of people who are
experimenting with that right now most
of what you see in in terms of public
support for push it's going to be that
this link rel preload style and there's
a couple of reasons for that one is most
of the students today are built on
infrastructure that just doesn't really
support HTTP two in the origin side of
it so there's two sides to a CDN one is
to the clients to the browsers so you
connect to HB 2 and you get so
responds with hb2 but the CDN itself
that edge server has to make that proxy
request to the actual origin server and
almost none of them if any actually do
that over HTTP - they all seem to do
this over HP one so it's hard for
anybody service to actually implement
through HTTP - all the way just because
of the technology stack that they're on
secondly is that from the perspective of
CDN they're not trying to solve a
front-end developer problem they're
trying to solve a network performance
problem and the solution is potentially
sufficient so me as a friend developer I
see server pushes like this amazing
solution to make my website faster
automatically without configuration and
all that to them what they're trying to
solve is that think time that server
think that in that little round trip and
so as long as they can serve a single or
maybe a couple of assets it's fine this
sir
so your initial request comes in and
they have that edge cache they have a
couple of files that that are included
in this link preload that they can
immediately push then they're filling
that thing time already and so that
narrow performance issue for them it's
considered done but you'd never be able
to like push you know 100 javascript
files and 100 CSS files because your
letter your header would just like be
crazy long and most of these servers
sort of have a limit on the size of
headers and I like CloudFlare I think
something like 24 maximum link preload
25 or something capped they have pretty
low limits on these things so like for
for bundling and a whole bunch of assets
it's not ideal and so this is one of the
problems that I've faced and why I
prefer to go over something like node
where you have full HTTP - in any
direction you want like you can easily
proxy full HTTP - from the client to
your proxy and from your proxy to the
upstream right and so that's one issue
second issue this is the second issue
this is an example here our our hello
world the second time I load this page
right I make the same two requests and
[Music]
ready to go the same thing gets pushed
but I could already have this in my
cache I mean I already have this in my
cache on the first time I loaded it but
it's still being pushed so this being
waste
and it's pretty who has a mechanism
where the client can sort of reset as
pushed stream so to reject it
but it could be that if you're pushing
like a whole bunch of files that just of
just do just a volume of push promises
itself could be you know kilobytes and
then the resetting each of these
individually could be like tens of
kilobytes so you're wasting potentially
a lot of bandwidth that self will take
round trips and so this isn't less than
ideal
to just rely on the client to cancel it
also the server might have already in
the meantime sent it out if you like two
seconds away the server could already be
like sending a whole bunch of data that
your client will eventually just like
reject or find useless and that's again
wastage and so the solution to this is
for the client to tell the server what
it already has in its cache it does that
wazzle this thing is called cash digest
that's the proposal that's if you go to
the HTTP working group you'll see cash
digest proposal it's the concept of a
bloom filter I'm not a computer science
kind of background guy but I implemented
it and the way I understand it is that
you basically look at everything that's
in your cache for this domain that
you're connecting to
you take a hash of it so you have this
nice normalized random noise this
distribution and you take the first
couple of bits you sort of stick them
all together and you pretty much send
that to the server so your server has
this list of abbreviated hashes of all
the things that are in the clients cache
so this takes a lot less bandwidth to
transmit than just sending all of the
URLs right so it's just nice and
abbreviated and the server will then
just say okay I'm trying to push this
thing but I can look up in this cache
digest whether or not the client already
has it by just hashing the URL of the
thing that I'm trying to serve
abbreviating it and seeing if it matches
any segment in that bloom filter that's
roughly how it works to my understanding
so this is a minimal processing cost and
at a server and a client side but it
saves the server from doing a lot of
wasted round trips and network
performance is way more expensive than
CPU performance right it's very like
most CPUs on web servers it can be
practically idle serving you know 10
gigabit links it's very you know easy to
copy the copy buffers around so it's
kind of nice to have something to throw
CPUs at now but this hasn't been fully
implemented yet in any browser on the
market right now is still experimental
and right now the proposals I'm
switching from room filters to golem
coated sets do cocoa filters and each of
them have like some pros and cons and
from my conversations with browser
developers there's some difficulties
there and so some people are still like
ok why don't we just stick with this
link preload cuz it's Hana it kind of
maybe solves enough of the problem but
to really really bundle like large
front-end applications with server push
you would need something like a cache
digest and so one of the things I did
was to create a experiment with a
serviceworker that sits in the browser
so you're up
has to actually include the
serviceworker it didn't hook syn to any
fetch calls that the browser makes and
uses the cache API that the server
worker has access to
um cache digest and rather than
including it into a an HTP to frame it
just sticks it into a header or in a
cookie and passes it to a server your
server processes this and so this
requires a lot more like setup and a lot
more infrastructure a little bit I guess
but it doesn't require browser native
support and it works great and another
way of doing this was to do this on the
server your server kind of calculates
the digest based on what it has
previously sent and this is being used
now by this thing that I'm not supposed
to like really mentioned publicly but
it's open and public's or whatever
there's a project under a certain
internet search company that is supposed
to like give you automatic push support
for FASTA file and maybe general in
general and this basically uses the
server to generate the cache digest the
downside to that is that the server
doesn't know when something drops from
the cache and that's a big downside so
then you might have false negatives or
false positives depending how you look
at it but basically it could be not
pushing things that are no longer
available in the browser's cache and
then just the client has to make those
requests anyway and so there's there's
downsides to all these things until it
really gets into the browser it's always
going to be a bit scrappy and you know
hacky but it already solves like a huge
amount of the problems that you have
with bundling huge thousands or hundreds
or hundreds or thousands of assets so
cache digests it's a really cool
solution and it's sort of experimental
thing but if you want to set it up look
at the serviceworker it's on my npm and
all that i've written blog posts and
articles about it it's really good so
yeah we've got the two strategies you
can either create a manifest for like
what do you want to send personally I've
been going with this manifest approach
mostly the the tracking kind of model
was introduced by jetty like this java
application server like many years ago
back back in the SPDY the speedy days
before HTTP 2 or standardized so the
idea is with with the automatic tracking
thing is that it automatically generates
beta based on statistical model when you
get a request you send a couple
responses and you say ok typically I get
these responses sent to this request
and after a couple of users generally
get a pattern and from then on maybe
like you start using that probability to
send out all of those push streams every
single time and you can combine that
with a cache digest and get a really
good approximation of you know close to
perfect automatic push support the
manifest is basically you use like a
build tool or a manual can evoke and
configure it is to say if I'm serving
this HTML file I need this dependency
and if I'm serving this CSS file it's
including this plant and/or this image
and so a build tool could build a
dependency tree and generate a nice
manifest that your server or your CDN
edge could then use to push the correct
assets I've built a tool that does that
I haven't built the defensive tracer but
I've built a tool that uses manifests as
a concept and I found it to be quite
effective when you previously in the
good old days when we could still load
co purchased it would actually push the
various assets I'll show you how that's
actually has been set up I don't know
where the tab is here
so a very simple configuration that we
did for ku PJs was to say the manifest
includes a single rule where the blob
which is sort of like what was being
requested if it matches any HTML file
then you push the favicon and any asset
that match these images CSS and
JavaScript so it's a very simple rule
that just pretty much pushes all the
assets that matter to the HTML page it's
a very simple page also so you might
have more like you know slightly more
complex pages there's a concept of code
splitting in like some modern build
tools this is effectively the same thing
but with server push so you could say I
have an I have an entry point for
index.html where I need to push these
things and have an entry point for app
that HTML where I push these things and
in this case the this is this this
website has a landing page that's a very
simple fast loading web page and it has
a dashboard which is like a single page
app and I can put these with two simple
rules I can push all the correct assets
automatically um the way this manifest
works is not very well documented right
now no sorry sorry to say we're working
on that and this is this is one way of
basically making server push very usable
rather than having to hard code all of
the you know streams or push and push
stream and this is a really convenient
way and I'm I'm going to be exposing
this as a middleware that you can use
with faster fire or anything else as
well currently this is available in the
entire server project but the you know
the pain point there is that you need to
actually use this server it only goes
static files and for static hosting it's
great for static hosting it's very
convenient but I want to make it more
available to like anyone who can just
integrate this into their own web
application I think they'll be more
useful this is so far been more of an
experiment so okay here this is
basically exercise we're kind of like
we've kind of like talked about this now
if you want to do this exercise
feel free to set it all up the
instructions are right there but let's
see oh one thing I should point out this
is kind of a annoying gotcha
that I that I thought would save you
some time if you encounter it this is a
maybe not so valid HTML page
but regardless a script tag type module
this is how you can do es modules in the
browser it works cross-origin equals
used credentials so if you do not put
this use credentials thing your browser
will still make an extra request for the
asset you'll be pushing the certs are
really pushing the asset the browser
still makes an extra request it's this
annoying little thing that you have to
do on the initial script tag all that
all the dependencies and everything else
doesn't matter anymore once once the
original entry point has that
credentials cross-origin attribute so
yeah because otherwise you'll find that
this is quite weird to deal with let me
show a little project that actually uses
this this is - okay this is -
manufactured so let me skip over this
for now I'll show the actual website
that uses it so my goal here was to use
server push get a water please
my goal was to use standards as many as
much as possible so I'm using server
push for bundling no build tools that
are really doing anything substantial
thank you very much
you
yeah so I've got a fallback for 200
response that just goes through my
client-side router and my manifest like
I showed before it has an index for the
static homepage and then the app which
is the product if that gets served then
it pushes all of the the web apps assets
styles Java scripts images fonts and ID
and I can exclude things like source
maps because when I'm serving the app to
a normal browser like I generate the
source maps on the server so when I open
up my inspector the inspector will load
them but other users never need to
either download the source map so we
wasted bandwidth so I just exclude them
from the server push their otherwise
because I'm just using a simple wildcard
it would include them so I have to
explicitly exclude them here now I mean
this is just like a simple single page
app where's my OK in my entry point app
that HTML and like I said I have to do
this type module cross-origin News
credentials so I've got an entry point
app GS
what I said is okay and then from here
I'm just using import so and this is all
like not transpiled this works in the in
the browser today I've got a little
client-side router that I'm a simple
thing that like a couple dozen lines of
code that just does some nice routing
you but you could use your react routers
or what have you here I'm so for each of
these routes
I'm instantiate in a custom element by
its tag name and these elements have
been defined by their respective
component files which are just
JavaScript files that define like for
instance the login thing that we saw
worst so that's coming from
authentication login so the javascript
file authentication login as a template
element or extends in this template
element which is an element I just like
loading some HTML from its own attribute
here and then you start setting up your
callbacks and this is this is your web
components custom element style of
development that that you know I've been
working with so there's no JSX it's a
little bit more for both it's all Dom
but it's it works its high-performance
it works right now it works very well in
Chrome and Safari Firefox is still
lagging a little bit on web component
support but I know I feel like that'll
just catch up and I'm building this not
for like use right now I'm not building
this for legacy users I think that my
target audience is people were
interested in server push on HTTP to are
probably people are using like state of
the art stuff anyway and if this you
know it gets adoption and couple of
months from now chances are that even
Firefox will come around and implement
these things and ship those things
should probably talk to some of the
Mozilla people here about that but yeah
like my concern was not so much with
like full compatibility support but I
was actually amazed that it worked as
well as it did when I started developing
this I was expecting it to be completely
broken and besides a few minor glitches
like that credentials thing on the
script dog I was amazed at today just
work with full web components with the
v1 in spec with server push that just
works really well this like occasionally
you see like weird behavior when you're
like command-r reloaded in Safari and
sometimes it like does a lot of get
requests and you don't understand why
and there's some issues here and there
but like it kind of works and these are
just bugs that are gonna get fixed by
other people so my project will
automatically like will get better for
free over time all right
so this is a little project I want to
show if you're interested in how it work
just like it's all open source go
through it um how do you happy to talk
more about it but um it is the main
thing I wanted to show I wanted to show
the this static scene yeah um I'm
guessing it's down as well since we knew
from an observer so I've essentially
turned the server project that I have
into a SAS if you will it's a free
platform where you can just deploy
static sites so i usually i would i
would use github pages or serge a sage
or or nettle if i all these amazing
products i would use those but none of
them really supported HTTP to server
push and so i wanted to combine those
things so I've built with node.js I've
built a little sass called HTTP to live
where you can just deploy
with a manifest and it will just serve
it would push and my prototype has just
been one node at my house you know I've
got a nice gigabit connection and like
my house is less than a millisecond away
from the internet exchange in one North
it's kind of sufficiently fast compared
to an ec2 instance but effectively right
now I'm in the process of upgrading all
that infrastructure from this proof of
concept into a more production capable
actual global distributed CDN with
multiple nodes and pops around the world
and it's still a free open source
service it's I think one of the only
open-source CDNs out there and it's all
built on nodejs and I'm having a lot of
fun like actually playing with all this
technology and making it possible for a
lot of people to host their sites and
get all that amazing performance so I
hope you took away some things from here
and there thanks for bearing with all
the compatibility issues and everything
that we faced this is just the nature of
doing state-of-the-art stuff used to
spend a lot of time fixing little things
and then you go like why does this take
4 hours to find one little you know a
little missing dependency or whatever
that's just how that's sort of how it is
but if it's really good once you get
something working that no one Ellen the
world has done yet and once you start
contributing to like node.js core like
like a year ago I wasn't doing any of
that
no just stuff oh I only got into it
about about that time because I saw that
like people like Matteo and James and
they were working on this stuff and I
was like trying to just contribute to it
I was just writing some tests for it
you know I saw like some of the api's
weren't like fully fleshed out yet and I
just started doing little patches and it
was just amazing to see the how
receptive they were to it and the whole
community of around node.js core has
been really welcoming to these kind of
patches so I highly recommend that if
you see any bugs just going to do a
little pull request you become a
contributor to node it's a really good
feeling to I just that your your your
little fix goes out to millions of
people around the world and millions of
servers are running little patches that
you submit it it's a really nice
experience to go through that
it's anyway I would say go play with
these things and make awesome things so
I think that's pretty much the end of my
talk now thank you very much
Oh so
[Applause]